Josh Manson drifts back Manson feeds it across
they're in on side nice pass to the doorstep and
a chance in tight is stopped by Philip gusterson
long shot patted down was wondering whether he
should pinch or not and it costs Minnesota the
zone caprisa right back in deaking dropping Marco
Rossi rolls one to goal it's scooped up face off
Wi for Minnesota Matt baly carries it around the
net being harassed by Caleb Jones baly shot boy
that may have raised off the arm of goria just
one goal this season there's a great play though
just patient he's talking about moving his feet
continues to take the open space right to the
hash marks a good shot and said this is where
you know you're trying to find confidence as a
score as gor harun up the wall but it's taken
away and NuSkin skates it out nushin Buton hooks
centers a chance here for Ross Colton across great
save by gust maybe extending some of those shifts
looking for that offense to get going miles Woods
circles the net here another newcomer for Colorado
maard dancing from the line activating centering
the puck redirected in tight gust there for the
save that b he to the puck in the corner so you
think Alex about these team building moments and
hopefully it pays off for them talk to Pat Maron
he said they had all a great time drop pass Bal
he shot yor out a piece and enrolled in the nhlpa
player assistance program and we hope that he
gets better and gets the help that he needs
Middleton scooping one to go it's off the glove
of poror back to ma half speed pass McKinnon to
ma up top Ronin moving in SE August batted at by
Spurgeon out of the Zone McKinnon exchanged with
chushin over the line the chushin to the net save
gusterson rebound out of FR he made another save
was in the right position to get to the puck and
the wild [Applause] clear three shots on goal for
Colorado including that rebound chance on this
Power Play 50 seconds left on it with speed tuy
in over the line centering and gers came across
tough to tell him the first nine games completed
today Buffalo coming back to win against pburg one
of the two miles wood long shot sticks say gust D
tries to square it up for Duan out of the corner
Colorado able to take it away toughy beginning
the breakout they fire him up ahead leaving it
there and a shot they score it's Ross Colton
and Colorado strikes first well look and we said
guson was was playing well but this is just a nice
exit out of Their Own Zone the the family in the
building they come home T makes the initial play
and then it's Colton with just a great shot
posted in but look at tuy there supporting at
his own Blue Line gets in he's looking for the
puck to make sure he's a support option and then
Colton makes the right read and just snaps it with
a beautiful shot second period underway hard Rim
jumps away from ranton inside of the net jushin
got to the puck tried to play it across from mckin
and perhaps one p two minute goano picks it up
and now a long shift for Colorado in the attacking
Zone Byrum pulls the trigger intentionally wi off
the end boards what a chance for kby [Applause] R
granson escaped to stick ERS over the line
McKinnon to the back Taz Fresh Off the Bench
McKinnon one timer score valer NuSkin on the tip
Colorado converts on the power play and it's two
nothing [Applause] Avalanche well if it is jusin
he has been red hot it'll be goals in six straight
for him Taves just over to McKinnon the onetime
and it's actually just off the shaft gusin off to
the right of gusterson and he's able to just get a
stick on it and the Avalanche have the two nothing
lead and what a blast by McKinnon wow just looking
for way out at this rate three on two here Rossi
over the line drop pass capr off to the middle
zcell tried to shovel it to goal perhaps one
pass too many Rossy turn around bit underneath
the goal tender and capriso puts it [Applause]
in and a much needed goal for Carill capriso
just his second and even straight this year
gets the Wild on the board this right answer
quickly there's a quick play to the zone and
great job to get this puck back as the Avalanche
turn it over Rosy just fires it and there's Capri
off able to get a stick on it in front and put
it past gorv here's the play watch the turnover
there's the turnover right there Jen absolutely
look at Capri off there righty stays in the hunt
for the puck that was just a nice attempt of the
pass Rossy smart play to get the puck on net and
Capri off he earned that one I mean tonight we
saw a couple rushes he'll feed both the top of the
circle five on three for Minnesota best chance of
the game touch pass finding Baldi stick handling
shooting save rebound save by yor Baldi waiting
passing Capri saw foron blocked by nus and it's
back to five on four passing from the score we'll
see if they can continue with the Rhythm in the
third yeah and that's the way I thought the wild
really took over the second half both teams have
had parts of this game has gone back and forth
we'll see what the the nice finish but it's the
pass in play that leads up to this Capri off
with the pass down low and Erikson look at the
strength in front there Capri off also there
to create some havoc in front but zukar who's
probably been the most consistent player for the
Minnesota Wild with the nice feed in front to find
Eric hasn't won a game since November 7th this is
a turnover and Olson drifts to the wall slings it
around the boards ugly the Manson shot misses well
high and wide Olson rifles it back to the near
side touch pass out in front score Curtis mcder
off the feed from Andrew cogliano capitalizing on
the breakdown in the wild end it's 3-2 Colorado
just too many times a little soft play to the
middle and there's the turnover olon able to
take it in gain possession put the puck down low
they just rotate this around and eventually it's a
breakdown watch the slot going to be wide open and
mcder not known for goal scoring but he wouldn't
know look at the little move to the backand when
a guy like that scores the whole bench just erupts
as he gives his team the 3-2 lead at the touch and
the boys and the patience Al for Hartman charging
down the left wing Hartman steers it to Felino top
of the circle surveying feeding the point shot tip
safe rebound safe gor the scramble unable to cover
the puck in front of him as Faber with the shot
there's Hartman in front chance he gets a second
chance and Ericson EG poino everybody piling in
think it's Harman who Molino hard pass broin D
Tod to fa moving in Brock Faber activating to the
goal line stopping up faor center Shot save by
Geogia centering pass for Harman wouldn't go Dan
by Erikson X fa makes the move and it's Erikson
that just spins away from the pressure sees the
opening takes the pass and a great chance but f
is there for M McKinnon rips to the hashes touch
pass back from Jen Nathan McKinnon to kale marar
wrist shot wide off the end boards this hits
the outside of the post from Ronin no call Joe
Hansson behind the Nets Puck comes to the side
of the net Jam attemp D scramble in the blue
paint Puck comes free and Byrum skates to the
corner with it fine offense these are the type
of plays watch a little Jam play xks NE he stays
with it one two kicks three chances and then you
got Capri off it came out but as the Avalanche
come down to help their goalie but that's the
mindset of ericon 5 Seconds and four faor up ice
a patch for zc Carell jumps away and that will
do it and this frustrating season for Minnesota
continues they have lost their sixth straight